I started out, you know, like a normal kid
in high school.
I used to just smoke
regular flower weed with my buddies.
And then one of my friends
introduced me to a dab rig.
And it would get to the point
where I was having to smoke that pen
like every 30 minutes
in order to keep the high up.
Concerns about marijuana
used to be the stuff of Reefer Madness.
But in Colorado, already
a decade into legalization, high-potency
products are birthing new critics.
We've had legalization here now
for a long time
and it has just wreaked
havoc on a generation of our kids.
Despite the millions in marijuana
tax revenue,
some residents feel
there have been unintended consequences.
The youngest kid I've seen that's addicted
to pot is seven. It doesn't matter
what kind of parent you are,
cannabis in our community is everywhere.
For a child, it's
as simple as going on to Snapchat,
finding out where they're dealing
and going and getting it.
Karen Randall is a doctor
at a large hospital in Pueblo, Colorado.
Sometimes touted as the Napa
Valley of pot, the former steel town
invited the marijuana industry
in to try and boost the city.
But according to some residents,
it hasn't worked out quite like that.
Here it is. Like in all its glory.
The Napa Valley of cannabis.
Yeah, that's
what the Napa Valley looks like.
A study in Colorado
found marijuana related calls to poison
control centers more than doubled
around the time recreational products
hit the market in 2014.
A separate study showed vomiting
related cases in the state also rose
29% from 2013 to 2018.
One of the big ones that we see every
single day is what we call scromiting.
And it's a combination
of screaming and vomiting
that is really kind of
peculiar to cannabis alone.
I would be vomiting like often.
I used to weigh like 150 pounds.
I got to the point
where as weighing 117 pounds.
So I went to my psychiatrist.
He actually did a scope
to see
if I had like gallbladder
cancer or something, which I didn't,
and there was nothing wrong with my
GI tract.
He asked me, do you use substances?
And I said, yeah, I use marijuana.
He told me that you can use too much
to the point
where it's called cannabis hyperemesis
disorder, which is where I was at.
Dr. Jesse Hinckley of the University
of Colorado first became concerned
about cannabis after seeing some youth
admitted to in-patient psychiatry.
These were youth typically
without any sort of previous
psychiatric history
who were presenting acutely psychotic.
So hearing voices,
seeing things, paranoid, delusional.
And pretty abrupt onset typically
after a period of heavy cannabis use.
Of more than 4,000 marijuana related visits
to emergency rooms or urgent care
in Colorado, 5% were diagnosed
with schizophrenia or psychosis.
That's compared to less than 1%
among the general US population.
Most people don't even know
what's for sale in dispensaries.
Like do you know what dabbing is
or shatter?
And they make them in flavors
that are appealing to kids,
Scooby Snacks flavored, Girl Scout
Cookie, Birthday Cake flavored.
Dawn Reinfeld helped form the group Blue
Rising to advocate for gun control.
But they've turned their attention
toward reforming marijuana laws,
the very same laws
that some of them voted for.
Look, if we want to say that
you need to follow the science on climate,
on fracking, on Covid vaccinations,
then we should be following the science
on high-potency THC.
But following the science
isn't as easy as it seems.
There's no consensus on what level of THC
makes the product high potency.
The market is also flooded with synthetic
variations confusing matters further.
Raw flower
usually starts at 20% THC or higher, up
steeply
from the 4% levels of yesteryear.
Concentrated products
like vape rarely start below 60%.
Many extracts like dab, wax, and shatter
go above 90.
It was my birthday party actually ,
so I took a dab and that was about 75% THC
the first time.
And then eventually I found out
that I could just get to dab
pen which would last me longer and in turn,
be cheaper. So two years of
just daily use at 98% THC.
Recreational marijuana is legal in 23
states,
but remains illegal under federal law.
The US
government is gathering data towards
a pledge to reconsider legalizing
by the end of 2023.
While Germany is also drafting regulations
to start recreational use.
I asked our hospital
how much it would cost
just to see a patient get IV fluids
and some medicines.
It would be about 5 - 6,000 dollars for a ER visit.
We see at least one a day.
So if you go, okay,
that's $5,000 times 365 days.
That's $1.8 million.
And then if you times it by
25 ERs in Colorado,
that's millions of
dollars. Spent on just the scromiting-
Just on scromiting alone.
Treatment
for America's drug habit often
comes down to mental health care,
which sometimes isn't covered
by private insurance.
Many such patients rely on Medicaid.
We're just cost shifting right? They’re
taking money in
and we're cost shifting
their medical care to the general public.
If you look at the trends in the numbers,
not only did cannabis go up, and the
industry will say, well,
of course it went up
because now it's legal
and everybody's using.
But methamphetamines went up.
Cocaine went up. Opiates went up.
And my test doesn't test
for fentanyl and of course
fenranyl has gone up. We're reaching
the record number of deaths.
January 2022 Colorado
started using a tracking system
that limited daily THC concentrates
per customer.
The compromise reached by legislators,
Blue Rising, doctors,
and the local cannabis
industry had immediate impact.
Medical marijuana sales fell
about $7 million. Overall marijuana sales
also contracted,
falling about 44% below their peak of $226
million in 2020.
You know, it's legal here.
It's going to stay legal.
But how can we have a regulatory framework
that protects
public health. For the legal
marijuana industry, the stakes are high.
This year in the US, more
than a third of the $34 billion in expected
cannabis sales will come from products
with high levels of THC.
The US
Cannabis Council says
millions of Americans regularly
consume marijuana products
without any issues.
Confusingly, some studies have shown
that marijuana can have both beneficial
and detrimental effects
on some mental health conditions.
But the industry can't deny
that the legal market has created
a new breed of supercharged products.
I honestly believe that if we had left
cannabis at the previous potency,
if they had left it at 2 to 3%,
we probably wouldn't be talking.